歡迎收看歌有酬必爆
是我們教學單元裡面
唯一的籌碼教學
小哥把他的獨門絕學
都在這個單元傳授給大家了
好 最近呢
大家常常在問我們
到底手上非常多的多單被套牢
有沒有一些返校商品
或是空單的商品
可以來學習的
當然有很多人講說
都跌到哪裡了
其實今天露營的時候
萬事又跌破了
才來講反向避險
才來講空單怎麼布
會不會太慢了
這邊有一個例子
還記得其實我們另外一個課
就是標股在線等的朱老師
有一天他也來教大家
空方怎麼做
很多人留言說
現在才交做空
等著被嘎吧
那時候是15500點
大盤又跌了1600點
所以好的工具
不管你在什么时间点学习
重点是你先学会了
学会了你会运用
不管多跟空
你都有好的工具在手上
这个才是最重要的
所以今天全真小哥
要来独门告诉大家
他最常用的避险工具是什么
而且这些避险工具
一样可以从筹码看得出来
大户的动向
它主宰了台股的方向
这个还蛮重要的
我们一开始好严肃
没有开个车
當然沒有心情開車啊
輸到都站不起來了
站不起來了
骨魚也很久沒有站起來了
真的嗎
這個很可愛 問某人
好 那我們看
假設你手上都是多單的話
最近真的很難過
可是如果說從這種萬七萬八
一直把多單爆到現在
我覺得也神人耶
都沒停損就對了
都不停損
他真的爆到是比較強勢的股票
對 有眾人
或者是他真心是在存股的
真心在存股也不怕啦
對 真心存股那真的可以啦
可是你假如又有點想存股
又想做價差的
又有點受不了了 虧太多
手上一定要點避險商品
假如沒有避險商品其實很痛苦
那我們來看避險商品
我們之前有教的像例如說融券
優點你只要開證券戶頭
開個資券戶
它就可以交易的
缺點槓桿小
比較小
一對一
沒什麼槓桿
第二個容易收標課費
補不回來
三不五十
我就說資不夠了
收你標課費
第三要強制回補
一年有兩次
最近也是強制回補的
密集期出全息
對 沒錯
最近很多
第二是認受權證
或者選擇權
或者选择权
它优点小资金就可以避险
100块200块都买得到
都买得到
缺点的时间价值会流失
第三个就期货
我常常是用期货来避险
优点杠杆很大
有的期货杠杆有到18倍
所以只用小资金就可以避险
不受停资券的影响
也不用怕停券
你还得回补
缺点呢
容易有超合的损失
万一你币太多
一个反弹
可能就赔蛮多的
所以避险商品有这些
先认识
胆子小的可以农泉
胆子可能大技巧也比较好的
期货跟权针都很好
那我们讲农泉
农泉也会大赔
有些农泉一赔起来
一赔起来四五百%
四五百%
都有可能的
你脚不停损
很多可能
放空最可怕的就是
它沒有一個上限
你不曉得天花板在哪裡
不曉得被尬到哪裡去
台灣至少還有一個漲停板10%
每天只尬你10%就好
但是國外呢
他們有的是沒有漲停板限制的
所以國外呢
有一些很厲害的投資人
他們放空了 陪慘了
所以我們特別講
放空的風險
遠比做多的風險高很多
例如說 第一個帥哥
帥哥嗎 怎麼不放照片
沒圖沒真相
下次給你 這樣很帥
這叫做比爾先生
然後這個放空的Herber Life
那Herber Life賠了10億
10億啊 哇
我跟你講 他們在放空的
他們都做什麼事情知道嗎
先放空 放空完出報告
然後賣線股
然後去各大節目遊說
你知道嗎 各大節目遊說
這個股票很爛啊
估值應該很低才對啊
結果被發現了
你空單這麼多 我來嘎你
所以放空最怕有人跟他對坐
那這些就是在節目講太多了
通常我們放空不敢講
不要讓你知道
讓我安心的空就好
我讓別人知道你空的股票
你會有危險
像之前其實像妖孽事件
也是有人跟青山集團對坐
你放空我嘎抱你
獨立沒有現貨
賠不起這些孽
對
好 那這個BX們
光這個Herbal Life賠了10億
很恐怖的
來 另外一個
這有點難唸
這好難唸喔
聽我唸
Gabriel Pratkin
加布里加布里普拉特金普拉特金先生普拉特金 有點難念那還有空方光這個加先生呢
他Gainstop知道嗎
這很有名喔
這很有名啊
展戶力量大
對 他空Gainstop 還讓人家知道
賞人就說你們之前太惡劣了
空我們股票還大肆宣傳
大家不管了 不管盈虧啊
就是要嘎爆你
他們就是網路串聯
一群股民網路串聯
跟Stop 這個創辦人
賠了70億美金
那整個空方賠了910億美金
所以做空股票 慢慢做
不要讓人知道
讓人知道他是有很大風險的
尤其你空現股
像他們空股票他們都是借券來空
對
借券你要還的 你要買回來
那有的受不了他買回來
一賠都是幾十億美金來算的
所以空線股這麼恐怖
我們來講一個比線股稍微安全一點
剛剛是我們先把放空線股的缺點
講給大家聽
但是試試讓大家知道風險
可是方法還是可以學的
接下來我們講放空
事實上你可以買反向的ETF
它比較沒有像剛剛那樣子被嘎爆的危機
它沒有被嘎爆的風險
但是它也有很多缺點
我們待會兒會講缺點
那這個反向ETF
目前檯面上的反向ETF有這麼多
例如說大家最愛的00632R
最資深的台灣50反一
成交量有說到三十幾萬張
已經很厲害了
還有是元大S&P原油反
还有一个奇优
还有国贷台湾加权反
富邦台湾加权反
这些也都是类似0050反
对NASDAQ反
S&P500反
道琼反
日本反
黄金反
上证反
还有恒生国企反
护生反
但是越下面成交量好像就越低了
越下面越来越美量
还有日元反
美债反
这些反的很多
反很多
但是上面成交量比较多
反骨的阵容
反骨阵容
都会有一个R
英文有个R
中文有个反
你看到英文有R就知道
它是个反的
反的就是看空的
看空的
那这些看空的
我们来看一下
我们再补充一个
有发现最近看空的
这些月线斜率
各位还记得月线斜率吗
好 瞧瞧往上斜上去了
往上斜
月线斜率0.5%
這就代表他已經走多頭首次了
忘記協力的請回去看歌有酬必報第一季
好 第一季
那這些股票呢很多都是月線往上的
那這些股票這個
因為最近大盤太弱了嘛
所以最近的反向ETF就有人進來買
那我們先來講他的優點
好 第一個買進頂多歸零
那不是跟全震一樣
吃個歸零高
你去放空GetStop
不是歸零可以解決的
可是全鎮有槓桿
這個還好 一對一的感覺
反應而已
全鎮可能是兩倍槓桿 三倍槓桿
那這個呢
這個歸零比較痛
對 這歸零起來是全部都沒有
但是我們做空的
做空的歸零還好
比較恐怖的是賠五倍 六倍
也對啦
所以這個頂多歸零已經算是優點
剛剛如果是個股的放空
可能被嘎爆
幾倍都有可能
你空100塊 嘎你到1000塊
都有可能
這個頂多沒有
所以沒有放空賠超過100%的問題
第二 不受停券的影響
你還記得我們之前講的這個漢訊嗎
漢訊就趁你融券強制回補的時候
要開股東會 有兩個月的空窗期
把你嘎到最高點 420塊
你看夠不夠狠
他們是趁你停券
強制回補
把你嘎爆
那這些反向一提
他們有停券影響
他也不用賣掉
所以他可以持續的持有
那第三呢
放空的都很害怕
面臨補腳保證金的問題
你放空限股
你是要先付個融件保證金
那萬一大漲
他會叫你補腳保證金
所以代表說放空有可能是賠超過100%
那買反向ETV就沒有這問題
那第四呢不用面臨轉倉
你假如空期貨你自己要轉倉
那買這個反向ETV你不用轉倉
他們自動幫你轉
但這種轉呢事實上它是另外一個缺點
好 轉倉的話就會扣掉一些些的轉倉的成本
對不對
好 但是你不用自己轉啦
它自己會運作掉
只是你在價值上會有一點損失
對 損失
而且這種損失很大
很大
所以反向疫情的缺點
我們要講清楚有缺點
第一個 內含期貨轉倉成本
所以它價值會一直往下
你現在看到00632
現在反彈到6塊
你未來假如大盤反彈的話
你可能會看到它跌破5塊
然後跌到4塊3塊
有一天大盤假如持續高檔的時候
它有可能會下市
所以這個比較危險
那假如沒有下市 它有分拆
也就是說它的價值會減損所以長期持有成本偏高所以反向ETF你持有的時間一定要短你純粹做避險
你不要做波段的持有
波段持有你的行情要看得很準
第二個
由於跌幅不會超過100%
所以這個00632最多漲到多少
因為它這波從5塊開始漲
它要漲到10塊
我覺得都非常的吃力
但是前波高点是23块
那23块套牢的人怎么办
永远无法翻身
没救了
是永远无法翻身
没办法翻身的
所以反向ETF它翻倍困难
它跟股票不一样
股票都有机会解套
任何烂的都有机会解套
但反向ETF可能是没机会解套
好
那我们最近来看一下
最近也是火红的一档反向ETF
這個00707R期
它有個期的意思是
期就是它避險會用期貨來避險
可是只要反向的
不是都有期貨的成分嗎
都會有
可是它期的更嚴重
因為00632它有
幣的標的不只期貨
是
那這期
原代S&P日元反一
日元反一最近日幣跌翻了
跌翻了
很多人想說日幣跌到0.25
沒看過那麼便宜的
跌到0.2
接下來又繼續跌
你看到繼續跌
這個元大S&P日元反映
最近就一直上漲
我們看從20塊也漲到了
快到24塊
短線也漲滿多了
這個有個分點
永豐金類壺
他就買在7張點
好大一筆喔
厲害耶
一買買1000張
兩天各買500張
你看買在7張點
後來大漲一段
這就是厲害的分點
但是這一檔剛剛看成交量很少
他為什麼買得到1000張
因為他們會造勢
他要買他就得賣給他
一天五都會造勢
所以不用擔心
所以各位你什麼時候要換日幣呢
你等永豐金內湖把它賣出來
日幣就到底了
大概就到底了
買在起漲點的人
可能都會賣在最高點
所以他賣出來
日幣大概就可以去買了
就可以跟著小哥去日本夾娃娃
沒錯 返鄉英俊厲害分點
記得看這個分點
好 永豐金內湖
他可能會預言日幣觸底
對 他滿厲害的
好 接下來我們來看一下
哇 這更狠了
好 最近風聲鶴唳
真的耶
這個不曉得在我們教學單元裡面聊一下
我們真的聽到很多人被查
但是他都不是我們台面上
會請來節目的分析師
也不是像小哥啦
或是說古魚
不是這麼怎麼講
正派的
經營的網紅型素人
他們是有一些好像開了一些社團
然後聽說講話也滿辛辣的
其實最重要的
你不要被查有一個很重要的
第一個
你盤中不要講話
盤中不要講話
通常我盤中我都不大會講話
我有聊聊
但也不大想聊股票
因為你盤中講話
人家會有干擾的嫌疑
而且截圖那麼方便
盤中幾乎都不太講股票
那你不講股票大概就沒事
盤後講的都還可以
你也不要講到點位
你說我買 你不要講點位
不要多少錢買 多少錢賣
對 這樣子有誘導的嫌疑
那你這裡講點位了
你記得你不要跟人家講說
你買 事實上你在賣
這很不應該
通常我買別的我就貼賠錢的給你看
我就真的賠了啊
你賠的有我多嗎
看到你賠那麼多 他就安心
還好我賠的比你少
他們就安慰了 他也不會去告你
大概是這樣 這蠻重要的
所以這個盤中不要講比較安全
當然我們很多分析師上我們早上盤中的節目
但是因為講話說實話有憑有據
股票的財報或長怎麼樣子
其實都講得很清楚
是沒有遭受到什麼壓力
只要不要謠言就好
不要謠言
謠言就比較危險
所以我們很喜歡講籌碼
講真金白銀
籌碼就長這樣
長這樣
我沒跟你講說這樣
股票公司的未來營收怎麼樣
我也不知道
假設我知道
搞不好我也被騙
但是我講籌碼
這都是發生的事情
而且這是證交所公告的
所以這個覺得是真的
你只要講真的都不會有事
好 我們來看一下
最近這個厲害了 這卡厲害了
新加坡瑞盈
它今天這個大盤跌300多點
我就看一下 算到昨天為止
它在這150天
也就是說從今年年初
它今年年初開始
它就狂買00632R
年初就買也蠻厲害
他的點位很漂亮喔
他買的點位就是台股的高點
那個時候你也可以說他在避險啊
因為台股漲到18000多點
說實話有些外資合理避險
對 我們也可以覺得他合理避險
合理避險
好 他在這邊買這麼多
你看這邊已經買了幾萬張喔
然後這邊在後面加碼
十幾萬張喔
這個是什麼時候呢
在4月多 還沒到5月的時候
還有16000多點
繼續加碼喔
然後呢
前幾天
就是你說放空
放空節目的那幾天
會被約去喝咖啡的那一天
他那邊大幅加碼這就你看都已經14000點了對 那麼狠查他查他不要查太小咖了你可以查他都已經1萬4千點了
他還在買反一
對 他買
他不是買幾萬張而已
他買96萬張
96萬張
從5塊錢漲到了6.34
不要以為不多
20幾%
真的蠻多的
這個漲那麼多
它一共在昨天的損益
算是5.8億
好羨慕
我今天盤中幫它出估一下
今天盤中已經到達7.2億了
羨慕 羨慕
賺這麼多
所以台股什麼時候只跌呢
很簡單
只要新加坡瑞典大賣的時候
大概就有機會
因為這個咖看得還蠻準的
大賣返鄉ETF
那代表說它覺得可能跌不下去了
因為反向ETF它是會扣血的
它買越久對它而言
是越不利的
所以有一天它大賣的時候
哇 大賣的時候
我也要來買0050了
好 就可以買在一個更好的價位
那當然大家也有在講說
今年其實外資非常會運用T50反
就是0050的反一
因為看到外資的空單
其實最近是翻成進多單
所以也有人
期货达人也有提醒
他可能避险避债反一
对
然后多单的部分
他也是双边币
他会增加一些多单的期货
可是其实反一买更多
整体来说还是看空
有提醒我们他们会这样做
因为很多产金媒体都会报
今天外资买超多少
今天外资买超51
还好还好
结果我们一看
买超T50版
其实买超的金额都放在T50版
所以你要注意一下
他到底买什么
外资今天大回補空单
但是买了一拖拉库的T50帆
所以你要看一下外资买超的
到底买到什么股票
他除了买T50帆之外
他还要买另外一个帆
叫00664R
国泰台湾加全帆
也是类似的商品
刚刚那个是T50帆
这个是连整个台湾都看帆
上市上跪加全指数
加全指数都看了
加全反也是從第一檔開始漲上來
從5.6元也漲到了7.1元
也漲蠻多的
加全反又是他
又是新加坡瑞鷹
能買的都買了就對了
他買了多少張
23萬張
這很多 因為這檔成交量沒有剛剛那麼大
對 盤中看一下是賺1.8億
我們從盤中的數字算一算
他已經達到了2.4億
賺很多啊
那怎麼辦 現在如果手上都是多單的
再去買反一
好像又有點太慢了
永遠都有這感覺
對啊 其實跟各位講
不會每天跌300點
對啊
每天跌300點 跌到中秋節
台灣都要歸零了 你知道嗎
不可能好不好
所以它一定會有反彈
而且這種反彈會很大
這次的反彈說實話等很久
因為有好幾個徵兆
我們都以為會反彈
因為包括外資在回補空單
包括政府在請大家收斂點
包括大家會覺得台積電法說
應該會說得很好
甚至包括大家覺得6月的CPI
也許就是今年最高
這些都成為一個認為有反彈條件
但沒有談
還沒談 但是因為還沒到
可能過幾天就反彈
因為不可能每天跌300
一定會有一天漲300多 400多
那你記得在大漲的那一刻
你不要又覺得說
哇 大漲了 我們要趕快
重返多頭
不要這樣想 沒有這回事
多單還是要減碼
因為那個反彈就是個人道走廊
這個多單人道走廊
讓你可以減碼一點的
當你反彈的時候你減碼一點
你減碼不完怎麼辦呢
你就可以來買一點
這個反向ETF
或者是你去空期貨
買選擇權的PUT
都可以來做避險
好 那這個
這個傢伙心跳不入眼
連這個都賺到2.4億
太厲害了
所以最後呢
除了這兩檔以外
我們還有其他的
也是大幅有進場
好 大家應該意猶未盡
但小哥在公開的版本
當然最基本的先教會大家
什麼叫做避險商品
可能有的人連這個都還不是很清楚
也把優缺點跟風險都提醒大家了
好 那也提醒大家
這個大戶如果今天在買反向商品
有一天大戶不買了
大戶賣掉了
他可能也就醞釀這檔商品怎麼樣
利空出盡的時候
所以在榮耀班裡面
我們還會再告訴你兩檔這樣的商品
大戶是誰
他什麼時候有可能獲利了結
好 今天非常謝謝小哥
教大家避險的原理
而且我們把風險先講到前面
有提醒大家
如果您是用個股在做避險
放空個股它有很多很多的限制
但是如果您懂得善用工具
買反向的ETF
短期上它是一個很好的
優點大於缺點的
但是長期的話
因為它內部是一個期貨機
是它有長期扣寫的問題
總之先了解起來
我知道大家會想說
都跌到1萬4000才交會不會太慢了
永遠不嫌晚
因為你不會
當要用的時候
你永遠都不會
這個是最重要的
好 那希望今天的歌
有仇必報能夠讓你的學習
更上一層肉囉
我們下次再見了
掰掰